whether it's on or off the runways
during the ready-to-wear shows Paris is
the perfect place to take the seasons
for fashion pulse designers street style
stars and models have been laying down
the laws of what to wear this fall one
thing is certain red is hot for the
color winter months industry insider
Vic's foster says this season is the
go-to hue red is a big color I think
that looks very good on a lot of people
it looks good on blondes and brunettes
and it's a happy color there's a great
connotation of love women are really
using it in accessories in total looks I
love the Allred trend as in red from
head to toe maybe a red t-shirt or
sweater red pants red shoes super cool
on the runway the German model showcased
another trend checks designers have
above all revived respectable
houndstooth for sharp tailored looks
german singer lena meyer-landrut tech
mate
the checkered coat and herringbone coat
are making a comeback preferably in a
relaxed oversized cut check blazers are
all over the place right now and the
good old newsboy cap is also cropping up
again those are two key pieces you need
for a style update without looking like
you're trying too hard
news boy hats or Berets are the season's
must-have accessory with designers
embracing them everywhere from maria
grazia curie at your to johanna thing
for her wonder nikon show these berets
are a huge trend they're still from the
pre season but they're here to stay it's
no secret that denim is here to stay but
besides its perennial popularity four
separates the latest look is head to toe
indigo
[Music]
there's a lot of denim and all the
collections it seems that even designers
that never use denim before are
interpreting that their vision of denim
but there's another trend this season
and that is comfort even thickness of
statement making pieces sweaters are
oversized coats to leave plenty of room
for cool weather layers
it's a look championed by French style
starring in s tilaka song I have the
feeling everything's getting looser and
more comfortable skin tight pants are
out right now we want to feel
comfortable in our clothes you see that
above all with coats and wide trousers
everything's a bit oversized like my
blazer for example looks a bit like it's
borrowed from the boys I like it a lot
it's more casual coats of skirts and
dresses are old on the long side this
season preferably in florals or prints
the generous slit to loosen up the
silhouette if I'm feeling sassy I can I
can show the leg long lengths don't have
to look prim and proper these outfits
are a case in point
another season must have stand out belts
to clinch the waist in a narrow width on
us actress Naomi Watts or a wide band as
worn by a nasty love Assange I'm glad to
be in fashion but to be honest I've
always loved white belts for the
silhouettes I think we're closer to the
body first of all or very oversized it's
one or the other and very often you will
see that the the waist has become quite
important again tassels and fringes
continue to crop up shimmying on hems
and cascading down dresses adding a
touch of playfulness to the game of
dressing up
[Music]
tassels work fine for me but fashion fun
and games aren't everyone's cup of tea
where I just wear everything black
that's what I did today I think black is
the you know is the main color and I
mean every season you can see all the
new fashion trends and you know for me
less is more simple
black is always a safe bet just add a
pair of red shoes for an unmistakably
on-trend look